make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and deep within the suicide squad
future state story which honestly is not
that great there's a secondary story
which i didn't know was there i was kind
of going through and i was like
yeah i wasn't really feeling suicide
squad it's not that it's terrible it's
just not really for me and i was getting
ready to close it out and i was like
wait a minute you know because i because
i read digitally so i had kind of
skimmed forward a bit to see if there
were going to be like previews for the
next issue
and uh and then it picks up right with
the future state black adam
and this is amazing right this is an
absolutely amazing story because we get
the return
of superman 1 million which is pretty
awesome now here's the important thing
to understand
those of you guys who are not really
familiar and i feel like dc 1 million is
one of the
many series we started on this channel
and just never quite finished i felt
like that should be my new year's
resolution
for this year to finish all the stories
that we haven't finished but yeah like
this basically takes place in the 853rd
century so it's exceedingly far
in the future at this point in the
future the main superman of the dc
universe still lives on
and there came a point where he just
like flew into the sun and just stayed
there for a long time but he just lived
there for eons and neons and eons he's
also traveled beyond the source wall
different things like that but the idea
is that superman one million
is just this ridiculously overpowered
character right he's
he's insanely opaque and in the dc one
million universe he's kind of presented
to us
as this sort of nigh omnipotent being
right i mean not necessarily on the same
level as like the source
or or like the presence if that's what
you want to call it whatever the case is
he's not really shown to be like a
person who can just create whole
universes but he is insanely powerful
and so what we end up doing here is
picking up with the hall of justice
right now the hall of justice of course
the main headquarters of the justice
league but this is justice league a
and the reason why is because in the
future in the 853rd century the justice
league is split into different teams
right you've got primary teams and even
tertiary teams but justice league a
is basically the main justice league
team right that's where the best and the
strongest members of the league
all come together to fight on a singular
team and so the result of this is they
end up picking up on this kind of
strange
device right this kind of strange object
that's traveling across the cosmos now
one of the other things that happened
here is you basically got planet mogo
and planet mogo's more or less similar
to what we're familiar with the planet
mogo is ultimately destroyed
but it is kind of a big thing here
because what we really kind of need to
establish
is that in the 853rd century a lot of
the earth-based territories
are now planet-based territories and
we'll find out more about that here in a
second but there's this kind of static
that comes in right this idea that like
something's coming in there they're
really not even sure what it is uh of
course you know planet mogo
basically being obliterated leads to
justice league a saying okay like we
need to intervene we need to act we have
to do something
enter superman 1 million who comes
flying out of the sun now of course he's
also got a green lantern ring and i
think that's a new development i don't
remember
superman one million having a green
lantern ring
and the original dc one million
storyline i could be wrong because it's
been eons since i read it right it's
been
a long time since i read dc one million
uh so i could be entirely wrong here
i'll kind of have to skim back probably
and verify
whether i'm right or not but the issue
is that this force that's coming here
immediately scares the crap out of
superman 1 million and the reason why is
because
it overtakes him right off the bat and
this is what's referred to they call it
the unkindness
but it's basically the seven deadly sins
now the seven deadly sins those guys who
are not familiar the seven deadly sins
are named after the actual seven deadly
sins from catholicism but they come in
the form of pride greed wrath
envy lust sloth gluttony uh but you also
have a few other things that go on here
right you've got dove who's part of this
you've got vandal savage who seems to be
leading it but you've got a few things
going on but the seven deadly sins are
basically these beings
that aren't in effect eternal because
the seven deadly sins represent the
nature of humanity right so
as long as there is life in the universe
there will be those who
are lustful right who just desire what
other people have there are those who
are going to be greedy there are those
who are going to be prideful who are
going to be wrathful who are going to be
envious who are going to be
uh who are going to be filled with sloth
i don't really know what the adjective
for sloth is and then gluttonous right
people who are i guess slothy
is would be the adjective for sloth but
nonetheless like that you're always
gonna have that kind of thing
in existence and because of that uh
they're basically beings that cannot
truly be destroyed they can only really
be contained and so what superman 1
million is facing off here
he's facing off against forces that
cannot be destroyed and they overtake
him right they completely and totally
overtake superman 1 million and this
happens in
seconds right it's not like it's some
battle that goes on for like
days right and then like you know with
all the power that he had superman fell
after like seven days of battle no no
this happens in
moments right in just sheer moments they
descend on him and that's the end of him
right they basically end up taking him
out now he's not fully
completely and totally dead and in fact
we're even told as much we're told that
like he could basically merge with the
sun and in time he would rise again but
it would be too late right so
so the the indication we're given here
is that whatever damage he sustained
is so extreme that he's of no use to
anybody now that he is by all standards
of measurement
debt and so with that with with the
justice league a watching this happen
and effectively seeing their superhero
god taken out in mere seconds
at that point i wouldn't say panic sets
in but a bit of hopelessness sets in
and this happens across the cosmos right
because you have the
the android the artificial world right
which is like where red tornado who's
who's you know
kind of like vision for marvel comics
but not really uh where he basically
hails at and all the different
artificial beings that exist out there
in the universe have kind of
consolidated into a singular world
they've looked at what happened with
superman 1 million they basically
calculated things in their head and said
nope we're not going to live and they
self-destructed
the the kingdom of atlantis no longer
lives in atlantis on earth instead they
have their own world right their own
water world that they basically live on
because humanity's expanded far beyond
earth right they've
basically expanded throughout the
entirety of the cosmos the atlantean
cruisers which are considered to be the
most formidable army
in all existence go cruising into these
guys and immediately get destroyed right
so these
they're literally they're cutting a
swath through the universe's forces
we haven't said swath in a long time but
they're cutting a swath of the
universe's forces right that's basically
what's happening here and so it's one of
these things where
hope basically looks to be lost that
seemingly out of nowhere this force has
emerged
that nobody in the universe can seem to
stand against and then wonder woman kind
of chimes in or at least wonder woman
one million you know one woman from
from the 853rd century chimes in and
says i have an idea i think i know of a
person that could help us and so what we
what we end up having them do
is transition to the planet of kandak
because remember kandack's not on earth
anymore it's now its own world which is
really kind of perfect
for black adam and his forces because
even when they were on earth kondok was
a place where it was like you don't come
here unless we say you can
it was one of those you stay away we
stay away and if you do show up here
let it only be because the world's in
danger and you absolutely need my help
and even then i will only help you if i
believe my people are in jeopardy
it's kind of a wonky bit of a situation
here but what you end up getting is of
course them arriving on the scene and
then wonder woman basically revealing
that she's been in a relationship with
black adam for centuries right they've
been a couple
for a long long time and so batman of
course knew
because he's batman you know he knows uh
but nobody else really seemed to knew
and and when the question's asked like
why didn't you tell us he's like because
it's none of our business man
it's not our concern who wonder woman is
banging right like you know if she wants
to tell us that's fine but we've got
other things
we've got a whole universe to protect
right who cares who wonder woman is
sleeping with at the moment and so once
they arrive here the way the black adam
has his
whole kingdom set up is really really
cool one it's very advanced
technologically and
two he has this kind of pyramid right
that exists out there
but within this pyramid is actually a
multi-dimensional space
right so it's like if you were to walk
into somebody's house and then you could
access
different dimensions from inside that
house it's really cool and it's really
really
awesome the way that it's done here and
so once they get in there something that
i want to draw your attention to
black adam looks like the rock he looks
like dwayne johnson like it's not it's
not a spitting image of dwayne johnson
and we'll actually find out how close he
looks like dwayne johnson here a little
bit because
they make him look insanely similar to
dwayne johnson here but
when they're talking to black adam black
adam you know where he was basically
made aware of what was going on by the
kendaki congress more or less right the
the council as it's referred to one
thing to know is he's not the ruler of
kondok anymore he's really more of an
ambassador the kondok has its own
government its own people who just kind
of you know keep track of everything
technically it's the kandaki senate
right but they represent
everybody across the entirety of the of
the planet but he's not the sole king
anymore which is kind of a change of
things but he's also seemed to have
found a far more peaceful life which
anybody who's been reading black adam
for any measure of time
is probably thinking good on you black
adam you've only been struggling with
like the harshness of life
eons like for thousands of years so good
job finding a small measure of peace out
there in the universe somewhere
which is pretty cool but uh the issue is
that as he's kind of telling them what's
going on
you know the whole idea is he basically
says the the the kind of
enemy that can't that's that's sweeping
through the universe right now they're
ancient
right and they're insanely powerful you
know technology is not going to stop
them and where wonder woman beseeches
him to kind of get involved suddenly
they're all met by the arrival of the
seven deadly sense now one of the
important things to understand about the
seven deadly sins
is they do have the ability to take over
the bodies of others because they are
for the most part
intangible a lot of you guys probably
recall that from like the shazam movie
or just reading
you know shazam comics over the years
but they they're essentially
concepts or ideas that can take on a
physical form but because they're ideas
because they're not really tangible
things they can inhabit the bodies of
others
and that's exactly what happens here
that with the justice league facing off
against these various forces
they literally like it's it's one of
these things where black adam warns them
like don't let them touch you do
you know don't let them get too close if
they do like they'll consume you they'll
basically take over you
and that's more or less what is what's
kind of happened up to this point and so
what you end up having are all the
different members of the seven deadly
sins taking over
these various people now one of the
things that happens and this was kind of
bonkers about this and it's almost a
little
a little strange but at the same time it
kind of makes sense the sin of
wrath goes immediately after black adam
right because we know that historically
speaking
in dc comics black adam is a wrathful
character right he's just filled with
wrath and anger and rage
and so wrath immediately goes after him
because each member of the sense seems
to be going after each individual person
that's the most most conducive to the
nature of that particular synth and
black adam has always been a wrathful
guy and that's exactly what happens here
that wrath
more or less seems to merge with black
adam and when that happens black adam's
old wrath his old anger and rage
basically when he shouts the word shazam
ends up kind of rising again
now the reason why i say this is that in
that moment when he shouts the word
shazam
that the wrath entity is totally
obliterated right it's completely and
totally destroyed and we know that works
because
only magic can destroy these various you
know we're not really destroyed but only
magic can contain
these various beings who are out there
now because of how this goes down there
doesn't really seem to be an indication
that uh wrath is contained it looks like
he's destroyed right so presumably we'll
find a little bit more about that here
in a little while for the most part the
other members of the justice league
are taken over by their wrathful
counterparts that black adam's able to
throw a bunch of them into space but the
only ones who are really left
are uh are wonder woman and like of
course mitchell basically his friend
right and so grabbing the two of them
and whisking off he takes off into the
into a pocket dimension
and then goes to goes into a place of
hiding right now the issue with this is
that
each one of these places can be accessed
as long as you're in that main foreign
for your area right so like the
vestibule more or less and so because of
the fact that the door's just been
closed behind black adam it's only
really a matter of time
before all these forces managed to break
in right before all these forces come
busting in and one of the things about
this that's so crazy and this is the
moment where i tell you that like black
adam looks almost exactly like the rock
but one of the things that happens
is he basically starts to give up right
he kind of acquiesces and the reason for
this is because black adam has lived
countless years right thousands upon
thousands upon
thousands of years and the the way that
he kind of tells this little bit of an
origin story for himself not really in
origin but kind of giving us a summary
of his own history is that he was locked
away for thousands of years by the
wizard shazam
after he basically turned evil and in
response to that he kind of endured this
life of torture where all he had in this
room
was a singular source of light to remind
him how alone he was now eventually he
was
able to escape and because he was able
to escape he in turn took all this
this struggle all this torture that he
endured and turned it into a wrathful
state effectively so
angry over the life that he lost for
himself in the thousands of years he'd
been locked away but as time began to
progress
he began to kind of fight through and
and get past all this anger that he was
coping with and find some measure of
peace in the world and so this
garden that we first saw him in in this
story is where he was planting a flower
for every single person he's known that
he's
lost over the course of his life people
he's been in love with friends he's had
which is kind of crazy i never imagined
black adam having friends but like
things like that like all the people who
were significant to him he planted a
flower for each of them which is really
his way
of coming to terms with the struggle
he's endured and finding a better
place for him to exist and so as he says
this he kind of looks back and he and he
asks himself kind of muses out loud he
doesn't really know which one's worse
whether it was the the thousands of
years locked away
inside that room or the thousands of
people that he lost this is interesting
to me right because if you look at it
for what it is
right in the thousands of years that he
was locked away inside this room and it
was just him
that was it it was only just him dude
nobody had any expectations of him there
was nobody out there that he had to
concern himself with losing it was just
black atom and i will say from my own
personal experience there is
comfort in solitude there's a lot of
comfort in solitude so much so they can
actually become addicting and i know a
lot of you guys out there know what i'm
talking about right worse just
you in the world you know by whatever
manner and whatever means maybe you have
family you never talked to
maybe you lost your family right but you
never really have any friends that you
hang out with it's just you and that
solitude
can very much become addicting because
it's just you in the world and what
anybody else matters isn't necessarily
all that important i mean it matters
right you're not a narcissist right but
at the end of the day the expectations
you have for yourself are the only
expectations that matter
and so black adam basically cope with
that now the big difference between what
he's going through in that situation and
what we probably have gone through over
the course of our lives is like we can
go
shopping and like we can go on a
vacation
right we're not confined to a room and
forced to live there for thousands of
years
but you know it also kind of makes sense
that when you when you look at him
becoming free and then forming
meaningful relationships
and then losing meaningful relationships
because they simply grow old and they
end up dying and having to watch those
individuals die
over and over and over again right
finding somebody he falls in love with
they grow old he does not they die he
moves on he falls in love with somebody
else they grow old they die he does not
and the cycle just repeats itself over
and over and over again
would be enough to really cause all
kinds of of
just emotional torment on a person and
so in a lot of ways he kind of looks at
his time in that cell
and sees it as far less of a torturous
situation than he does when he was
actually out there living in the world
that life is harsh and life can be cruel
and life will take things from you right
whether you wanted to or not and so
because of that he finds this little
glimmer of hope when wonder woman
basically says well i'm pregnant with
our child now i'm gonna be honest
i don't like that um it just it feels so
easy right it's like batman it's like
superman and wonder woman being a couple
right it's just
it's easy it's just it's the easy answer
and so it is kind of cool that it gives
black adam something to live for and
black adam having his own progeny
but it's also it's also kind of like but
really like you know but like i'm
pregnant so like you have to fight
you have to fight your save our kid and
it's like okay you know i feel like it
took what was otherwise this really
really compelling situation
that could have just ushered in this
amazing character arc for black adam
just
you know kind of this this this third
stage of his whole situation right where
it's kind of like black adam emerges
he's full of wrath he only cares about
himself and his and
then he graduates and starts caring
about his people then he graduates into
love and caring about other people
besides his own people
and now he has something to fight for
right like the fact that he could be a
hero and save the world
and save the universe instead it's just
like okay i'll do it for our child you
know
it just it kind of turns me off a little
bit to be honest you know it kind of
kind of sends me off a little bit not
enough that i hate the story but enough
that it felt like i
could have been a different option but
while all these forces of the the seven
deadly sins just come busting in right
these these guys come smashing into the
room that what you end up getting is the
arrival of gold beetle presumably
well i won't say the love child of a
blue beetle and booster gold even though
i would
kind of love to see that uh she
basically comes busting in and is like
believe it or not
i know how to save the universe right so
obviously a kind of combination
of probably all the money of blue beetle
with you know the craziness of booster
gold
wrapped into one neat package who's
going to help them save all of existence
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]